hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that's gonna improve your
day definitely
uh it's a suggestion from danny davis uh
he used hashtag suggestions in the
comments so thank you for that and it's
a game from the ussr championship 1974.
uh it's a game between these two
fine gentlemen uh rafael naga rafael
ghanian and victor kupreschick
uh and uh these aren't the exact photos
of the time
when the game was played because it's a
very those photos are very hard to uh
uh you know uh find but uh they are
you know at least uh a little bit older
so i hope you guys don't mind that
uh but it's not an easy in in an easy
thing to find uh so it's like i said a
brilliant game
pieces are hanging all over the board
all the time and it's uh
uh you know just a normal normal opening
that's being played even today and then
all of a sudden you know everything just
comes crashing down
uh so without further ado let's check it
out and hopefully uh this
does not happen to you in your own game
so the ghanian with
the white pieces uh opens with d4
uh we have knight to f6 bishop to g5 now
going for the trompovsky attack
uh and now c5 striking in the center and
black would very much like uh
to trade this uh less than central pawn
for white central pawn
so white simply advances it to d5 and
now queen to b6
uh trying to take advantage of white's
early development of the bishop
by attacking the queen with tempo the b2
pawn is under attack now
uh knight to c3 white sacrifices it
for rapid development and this is all
very standard stuff we have queen
captures on b2
and now uh the knight is hanging so you
can't really play
rook to b1 right away so you have to go
back with the bishop
bishop to d2 so yes you kind of have to
go back which is a little bit weird
you've sacrificed material only to
pull your pieces back you know from from
where they came from
but it's only temporary as you'll see so
queen back to b6
black is of course expecting rook to be
one uh and now uh
e4 grabbing more space in the center we
have d6 by black and
now f4 white grabs even more space in
the center
and we'll try to execute e5 as soon as
possible
so g6 black wants to play bishop g7 and
castle to safety and if black is able to
do this then black grabbed the pawn
he castled the safety and then he's
going to have an okay game
uh where he will look for his chances in
the future uh to try and convert that
extra pawn so here we have e5 by white
white wants to keep the black king in
the center of the board for as long as
possible
d captures with f capture on e5 and now
knight
f to d7 and now as the e5 pawn is under
attack we have to defend it we have
knight to f3
uh and here bishop to g7 so black almost
accomplished
everything that black is dreaming of he
wants the castle and that's it white
does have a very strong center
but if you don't have anything concrete
you're still down a pawn
but here black misses one crucial move
and well i'm not gonna tell you which
move it is feel free to pause the video
here
and try to find this move while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
uh getting rid of the queen because the
queen
should not keep an eye on the e6 square
this is crucial so rook to b1 this is
what black missed and now
black really doesn't have a good plan
here the point is uh you want to play e6
but you can't play e6 right away here
uh black can just capture and now if
knight g5 yes
go you're going after this pawn but
black can just capture this pawn as well
and nothing good is really happening
here if knight captures here just queen
to d6 and everything is nicely defended
black's position is perfectly fine so
here finding this
rook to b1 move is key so
congratulations to everyone who found
that
rook the b1 and now the queen has to
abandon the sixth rank all of these
squares are now covered
by the pawns by the rook by the bishop
here and the queen has to move somewhere
else so queen to d8 was played and only
now
e6 and this is where things start to go
really really wrong for black
so f captures on e6 and now knight to g5
with the idea of knight captures
attacking the bishop
and the queen so here uh maybe safest
is to just castle and allow white to do
this for example knight captures attacks
the queen queen moves and now
you're not even in a rush to pick up the
rook here on f8 you can just for example
play bishop e2 continue the game maybe
bishop f3
castles at any point you can just go a
queen uh
knight will either capture the rook or
knight the c7 attack the queen and the
rook
so black is not getting rid of this
knight that easily so instead after
knight to g5 we have knight to f6 by
black
and now comes bishop to b5 with
check and okay nothing out of the
ordinary we have king to
f8 the bishop is guarding the e6 pawn
that's
the important thing here and now d
captures an e6 so what do you play here
here there actually is one game i think
from 2001 or something like that where
uh uh where queen to c7 was played but
here we have a6 by cupracek
and it is uh as of move 15 that this
position has never been reached again so
this is now unique the bishop is under
attack
and this is one of those moments where
the fun
really starts so uh feel free to pause
the video here and try to continue this
game
uh for for white while i give you a
couple of seconds it's uh it's a
beautiful position
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
this idea it's not an easy one to find
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
not queen bishop to e3 you now threaten
queen captures queen and this is deadly
and if the queens get traded off then it
doesn't really help black because then
just rook captures
and then if a captures on b5 yes you
eliminate the bishop but not just
rook d8 check knight blocks and now a
nice castles here with
check we have to block this and now
comes rook
captures in c8 and there's not much for
black to do here
his position is completely terrible the
rook can't move because the knight falls
that this knight cannot move
the rook cannot enter the game if you
try something like king the g7 maybe to
try and get the rook into the game it
doesn't work knight f7
attacks the rook and now this rook falls
as well because if you move it you get
bishop to h6 checkmate so this is how
strong the position is for white
so instead after bishop to e3 queen to
a5
was played now attacking the knight here
and the bishop is still under attack
but black says nope this is not a
problem sorry white says and here
white just castle so castles here and
again
all of these pieces are hanging so let's
see what happens if some of them are
captured of course if the knight is
captured then queen to d8 is made in one
because the knight now cannot move
and it doesn't really help if you
capture the bishop if uh pawn captures
bishop then rook captures and b5 attacks
the queen
and after the queen moves we just
happily continue attacking that queen
queen to d8 and now bishop captures in
c5 and there really isn't
much you can do here knight c6 yes this
defends the pawn but now queen to
f3 and uh there is no good move here for
black
you could unpin for example king to e8
but now we just play bishop captures
remove the defender of this knight and
if knight captures just knight captures
on f6
bishop captures queen captures and you
are getting checkmated now
you can well prolong the game for a
little bit but that's pretty much it
so instead after this castles move by
white uh black decided to play h6
and this is even greater because now
three of white's pieces are hanging the
knight here
the bishop here and the the other knight
but
white simply doesn't care so feel free
to pause the video it's actually a
forced checkmate in 10 for white with
best play from black of course
so uh while i'll give you a couple of
seconds win this game for white
in great style
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting such a
such an amazing move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the weakness is
g6 and that's why we play queen to d3
now the thread is queen captures
followed by checkmate and
there is no good move here whatever you
try here simply doesn't work
uh to give you an example for example if
you eliminate the knight
we're still just going to capture this
threatened checkmate and now if king g8
uh trying to reach the h7 square you
simply allow that queen f7 check king to
h7 now bishop d3 check
king h6 and for example queen to g6 will
be checkmate
so that's not happening and capturing
any of the other pieces
still doesn't really do this is just
captures and checkmate
so here and you can't really capture the
bishop with the queen to try and get
back with the queen because then well we
just capture the queen that also doesn't
work
so here king the g8 was played by cupra
trying to
get the king away uh from the file right
away
but just queen captures and g6 this is
now the threat of checkmate and now the
pawn has to be eliminated bishop
captures and e6 was played
black says all right i don't have to
keep all of this material but now just
knight captures on e6 uh now threatening
checkmate here
rook to h7 and here uh well you could
finish this game in in well there are so
many ways you can finish
this game a nicer one would be something
like bishop to c4
now threaten all sorts of nasty
discoveries and if king h8
now you might even go for knight to f8
now attacking the rook here
and if the knight is captured now you
can eliminate
this guy here threatening checkmate and
now
of course after bishop g7 preventing
this you're gonna go queen to e8 to
check
bishop to f8 and now for example queen
captures an f8 checkmate
so there are all of these possibilities
here white goes for a different one
white sacrifices on f6 right away
it's not really a sacrifice you can't
really grab that because if you take
that
then just queen e8 check you're going to
get bishop to f8 and the now queen
captures an f8 so pretty much the same
stuff
so after rook captures an f6 we have
knight to d7
trying to create some madness here
attacking the the the rook here
uh but uh here white just played bishop
captures on d7
and it was in this position uh on move
22 that victor koprec resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh instead of this bishop captures
or black really has no moves here so of
course you resign
but instead of this uh i was looking at
a much
much uh well uh it's not a forced line
but it's
it's a nice one because for example
knight two you play knight to f4
you offer the rook and now after the
rook is captured it seems like
black is out of the woods but bishop to
c4
check king the h8 and the now queen to
e8 a beautiful queen sacrifice
uh now you capture the queen rook
capture 78 and now of course knight to
g6 a beautiful smuttered mate so even
ideas like these are in the position so
anything
really anything can be played here after
bishop captures on these seven
uh black black resigned the game and
this amazing
game was played by rafael vagany and
that you know will be
probably shown for you know the rest of
uh uh forever uh
because it's uh it's really an amazing
game uh and before i do
the forget uh here are the standings of
the tournament now you guys are always
interested in the standings
uh beliavsky and tal uh won the
tournament with nine and a half out of
fifteen and vagania and as you can see
got uh shared second place with uh love
pollugalevsky
with nine out of 15 points vigorous did
not have a great
tournament he ended on three and a half
out of 15
uh but he you know uh played one of the
games that
was probably replayed the most out of
all the games in this tournament and it
was this loss to rafael baghanyan
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it really an outstanding one i know you
guys
want to you know rush and show it to
everyone so
you know feel free to do that uh i would
like to thank sebastian beauchart
yossip mr hoody guy stephen mccann and
scott melis for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day